quand vous piquer bah oui super bien
oui alors il ya deux phrases qui montre
que vous êtes aura ça quand vous faites
vacciner
vous me dites on vous pique est rien
j'ai rien senti ça c'est les deux fans
et pas défoncer les bras de la terrasse
makota tu voulais pas te dira là c'est
sûr c'est emmanuel macron qui avait
écoutons viens tu vas aller se faire
vacciner
aujourd'hui ce n'est qu'il n'a pas les
piqûres je ne quitte pas les brûlures
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien
que le ministre de la santé ait fait ça
devant les caméras vous entendez à tout
le monde il ya des flashes et des trucs
bat nicole fini oui bah oui on va
écouter c'est très bien dit donner
l'exemple c'est vrai car et tout un
sujet autour du vaccin le prolo mise la
santé qui fait un vaccin je trouve ça
normal
alors bien sûr elle pas parole du
gouvernement bernard montiel et u18
également mais il a droit à se faire
vacciner dès maintenant parce qu'ils les
soignants et les neurologues les
médecins donc comme tous les médecins il
a droit est vacciné avec astrazeneca
d'ailleurs alors regardez il a
apparemment il a des parcs et rattrape
des aînés cas super belle allée français
galèrent pour se faire vacciner
il va se montrer on sait très bien qui
est en conflit avec le président de la
république et leurs proches plein de
choses notamment le retard des vaccins
je trouve que c'est démagogique
ça fait faux vous êtes un lobby très mal
à l'aise mais raymond répond lui stoppé
non c'est vachement bien parce que
évidemment qu'on aimerait avoir moins de
politique à la télé sur twitter on
aimerait qu'ils s'occupent du pays et
qu'ils arrêtent de faire des stars mais
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est qu'ils sont
tout le temps en train de me dire faut
vous vacciner faut vacciner
moi je veux que l'élite montre l'exemple
d'abord maxime toi d'abord avant de me
dire moi d'y aller sogepa nos charmants
vas-y toi les mecs qui disent tout soit
il faut se vacciner ils ont soixante dix
ans ils vont pas basit maxine et warda
banjo tu en as tellement tendu les
antilles max les complotistes les
lalanne de voilà bref tous ces gens là
ont fait beaucoup de tort à la campagne
vaccinale pour moi je trouve que c'est
très bien qu'ils montrent l'exemple
et pardon de gilles il fait partie du
peuple comme les autres les mini c'est
aussi des élus du peuple et je les avais
tous agents des différents ou ni mieux
ni moins bien fait face va très bien il
dit non désolé me disent tu es pas élu
du peuple
ouais c'est vrai y ont été nommés pas
peut-être un peu
de travail et qui y laisse sa dose de
vaccin quelqu'un qui en a vraiment
besoin de lui qu'il est médecin
enfin je pense qu'il n'a pas pratiqué la
médecine depuis quelques années pas du
tout dans les hôpitaux pour le marteau
le coût est pas il va pas en rire pour
le coup je n'ai pas faim voilà il n'est
pas représentatif un agen peut plus
avancer se fassent vacciner
et justement géraldine le principe des
antilles maxent et des complotistes et
d'être contre tout ce que fait et dit le
gouvernement donc là en voyant ça il ya
plein de gens qui ont à dire mais qu'est
ce qui nous prouve que c'est un vrai
vaccin est ce que c'est par un autre
médecin
je pense qu'en termes de communication
ça sert à rien non parce que les gens
sont de plus en plus favorable à la
campagne de vaccination lancée c'est la
sai totalisant qui va vers des
complotistes vous pouvez très bien le
vélo mais mais mais en tout cas les anti
vaccins guillaume c'est pas forcément
des antilles et un parce qu'on peut
travailler être anti lac st juste parce
qu'on n'aime pas en moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est que effectivement il
en fait la promotion c'est normal que de
la communication de suez pour le coup
c'est vraiment de la communication parce
que la personne qui dit ah vous m'avez
d'y appliquer j'ai rien senti ça ne fait
pas mal issa voilà une aiguille aussi
petite soit elle on sent quand ça rentre
est prêt il aiguille on est à la traîne
aussi et joe biden le premier ministre
israélien la reine elizabeth ii il était
temps qu'un membre du gouvernement
agisse
c'est le premier jeu by 2,75 à l'arrêt
m 18 mois on n'arrête pas de comparer
des vaccins ceci moins bon celui ci na
na na na donc oui le fait qu'il soit
vacciné apparemment sans crainte c'est
plutôt sympathique moi j'étais contre au
départ et finalement l'ayant vu je me
suis dit bouhenia pas fait rire c'est
plutôt sympa elle est contente
joe biden a effectivement accepté de le
faire mais emmanuel macron a refusé de
le faire parce qu'on lui avait demandé
de le faire il a refusé le faire et
qu'on sait que ce n'est pas une bonne
idée pour la paix ça c'est bernard
montiel
mais oui pour la communication
évidemment pas ce qu'on va dire pourquoi
lui les jeunes et pourquoi lui voilà ça
mais c'est pour tout ça parce qu'il ait
changé alors géraldine la vraie réservé
aux noirs donc il a des on-dit là il ne
peut pas faire vacciner dans ce cadre
voilà merci géraldine maillet on va voir
ce qu'on pense étaient les spectateurs
se lèvent accident direct oui 65% à 6
heures non à 35% voilà c'est plutôt le
reflet de ce qui s'est passé